[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Apigee X allows you to
expose your APIs to end users
by implementing API proxies.
API proxies are nothing but a
wrapper for your actual APIs.
Did you know that
the API proxy must be
deployed for it to be invoked?
The process of
deploying the API proxy
and making it accessible
to the end users
is referred to as
API proxy deployment.
Before you deploy
your API proxy,
you need to complete a set
of prerequisites correctly.
Networking and
routing configurations
are two of the key prerequisites
for API proxy deployment.
A key point to note, if
the configurations are not
defined correctly, then your API
proxies may not be accessible.
In this video, we will learn
the Apigee X networking
architecture and demonstrate
how to verify the networking
configuration of an
Apigee X organization.
On a high level, there
are three key things
to be configured in networking.
First, the Virtual
Private Clouds, or VPCs.
Apigee X instances
are proficient in
internet Google-managed VPCs.
However, Google-managed
VPCs are not
directly accessible
from your GCP projects.
Therefore, you need to
pair them either with VPCs
or shared with VPCs created
in your GCP projects.
Secondly, the Managed
Instance Group, or MIG.
Currently, GCP load balances
cannot directly route requests
to Google managed VPCs.
Therefore, you need to
use a MIG for forwarding
requests received
by the load balancer
to the Apigee X instance.
Be aware that this MIG needs
to be created in the same VPC
network attached to the
Apigee X organization
and an ingress firewall
rule is required
for allowing the load balancer
to route requests to the MIG.
Finally, the load balancer.
Depending on your
routing requirements,
you could either choose an
external or an internal load
balancer for routing requests
to the Apigee X instances.
Keep in mind that, if you
are using a shared VPC,
then ensure that all managed
instance groups, client hosts,
and target hosts are
created in the same network
as shown in this diagram.
All right, let's jump into
the Google Cloud Console
and verify the networking
configuration in a sample
Apigee X organization.
First off, let's verify
if the proper VPC
network is attached to a
sample Apigee X organization.
Open the Cloud Shell.
Execute the
following API request
to determine the VPC network
attached to the Apigee X
organization.
The authorized network
property in this output
refers to the name
of the attached VPC.
If you are using a shared VPC,
ensure that authorized network
property has the name
of the actual VPC that
is attached to the GCB project
in which the load balancer
and the MIGs are created.
Next up, to verify the
configuration of the MIG.
Go to Compute Engine
Instance Groups page
and select your MIG.
Click on the Instance Template.
Scroll down to the network tag
section and note down the tags.
Next, ensure the VPC network
defined in the network
interfaces section is the
same as the VPC attached
to the Apigee X organization.
Scroll down further to the
custom metadata section
and verify the endpoint IP
address against the Apigee X
instance IP address.
Navigate to the VPC
network Firewall page
and verify the
ingress firewall rule.
Be aware, this
firewall rule needs
to be created in the same
VPC attached to the Apigee X
organization.
Ensure that the
network tags of the MIG
are defined under target tags
and allow the load balancer
health check probs, source
IP addresses ranges,
are included under the
source filters section.
Finally, let's look at how
to verify the load balancing
configuration.
Go to Network services
load balancing
and click on the
load balancer name.
Under the front
end section, verify
that protocol, IP address,
port, and the TLS certificate
are configured correctly.
Next, if any host and
path rules are defined,
verify whether they are
configured correctly.
Lastly, under the
Backend section,
verify that the load
balancer backend is healthy
and it is pointing to the right
MIG, which forwards traffic
to the Apigee X instance.
To summarize, you learned
the networking architecture
in Apigee X and how to verify
the networking configuration,
namely, VPC, MIG,
and load balances
are configured correctly in
an Apigee X organization.
[MUSIC PLAYING]